Copy on a Tuesday and blog,
14 crosswalk buttons.
What do they work?
So contrary to popular belief,
people do walk in Los Angeles.
I come across the crosswalk button
almost everyday.
It usually goes like this.
I hit the button,
nothing happens.
Then I hit it repeatedly.
Nothing happens.
Then I hold it down as if to say,
come on.
Then something happens and I feel like
this.
I realize I probably just contracted
leprosy because I've been talking that
filthy buttons.
So what's the deal?
Is it all in my head or am I really most
at this article from the New York Times
in 2004 years?
Well worn push buttons have offered
harried walkers are rare.
Promise of control over their pedestrian
lives.
First of all,
you Michael Lewis
studied journalism.
Mass is probably the right adjective.
I'm making fun of Novelis.
It turns out the city,
the activated most of it's pedestrian
buttons longer ago,
more than 2,500
of the 3,250.
What?
Buttons that now exist function
essentially as mechanical placebos your
mechanical placebo,
but it's true with the advent of
computer controlled traffic signals.
Crossword buttons have largely been
deactivated.
Major cities.
Traffic is controlled by a centralized
computers executing complex timing pet.
It's how seth green can help Mark
Wahlberg get places in his mini coop.
But the article is about New York.
What about Los Angeles?
So is it,
is it true that there are certain parts
of the day in which
the,
uh,
the buttons won't affect
the,
the light because of the,
because of the,
because of the complex pattern
that I have not heard directly,
but I could imagine that that would be
the case where there might be certain
person the day where it's gonna turn
green on its own timing regardless of
whether somebody has thought about it or
not.
Because you know,
say if it's rush hour,
they want to get the cars brew.
Sure.
So placebos were everywhere,
yet still we press well,
the short answer is humans love.
But we've been conditioned all our
lives.
I believe that buttons do things.
Maybe you should just do it.
No,
it's at crosswalks.
We see ourselves pushing the button and
then we see the little white man cause
and effect.
Who cares what's happening in between.
We hit the stimulus and get the reward
that we want.
His tendency is called the illusion of
control.
It's an idea first developed in 1975 by
ellen langer.
A professor of psychology at Harvard
says that we overestimate our ability to
control events.
Here's one example in casinos at the
craps table.
It's been shown that people roll harder
when they want to get higher numbers and
software when they want to get lower
numbers,
even though dice rolling you,
unless you're George Clooney is a chance
event.
Suzanne Thompson,
professor of Psychology Pomona college
says that the illusion of control is
determined by a control your risk
puristic as an experienced based common
sense method of problems.
The control heuristic is based on two
conditions,
the intention to create the outcome and
the relationship between the outcome and
the action.
When I pressed the crosswalk button,
I wanted to chant.
It does change eventually.
That's according to the control here
ristick my illusion of control.
His strength.
I'm more likely to press it again in the
future.
Is this good or bad for me?
You have to decide that for yourself,
consider this even with higher illusions
of control,
are more likely to try new things and
subsequently do new things in those with
lower loop people who are depressed,
show lower illusions of control and it's
not hard to see why when you consider
their self worth,
but it has also been shown that people
with higher illusions of control are
more likely to commit to failing courses
of action.
It has been argued that a lack of
illusions is associated with a
non-defensive personality oriented
toward growth and understanding with a
low ego involvement in outcome.
Now,
I think this point is really important.
First,
let me say that we are Westerners in the
tradition of a western philosophy.
It means that we are doers,
actors,
believers in the will,
that it can create and change things.
I'm proud of that tradition and growing
up in it,
I know that I can never totally be a
part of eastern philosophy,
which is the opposite.
Though I believe that there are things
we can change.
I also believe that there are things we
can.
One thing we can't change is people,
and maybe that seems like an obvious
factor,
but I think sometimes we want it so
badly that we have the illusion that
it's in our control,
so maybe your short,
like 100 percent positive that someone
you know is going about something wrong.
Well,
it takes a non-defensive personality to
see that it would be wrong to try to get
them to do it right.
It may be a little bit counterintuitive,
but telling someone what's right for
them,
thinking that you know what's right for
them is a way of exercising control,
failed to imagine one another
complexity,
and in our simplistic view that we can
handle another's problems better than
even thinking it's an illusion.
We'd be better off.
Friend dependent will never fully know
until you let go of the illusion of
control.
Yeah.
The is the best animated movie.